audiences in nashville have been fine
they've been good we sold out six shows
they have not been as amazing as
texas i've been really getting into
texas a lot uh
we're really thinking about we're
thinking about maybe moving los angeles
we talked about this earlier today we're
thinking about getting out of california
and and it it's it it part of it is
the economic collapse the fires
the homelessness the civil unrest
the racial tension the policing
uh the lack of freedom the dirt
the diseases that are coming back the
high cost of living
a high property tax burden the high
income tax burden
the mismanagement of the state uh the
political
uh issues um the earthquakes
earthquakes the tectonic issues
that's just to name a few negatives
the death of hollywood how embarrassing
it is to even be in this business
the idea that everything is independent
now and you don't have to be in los
angeles to get any opportunities
and nobody's giving you any
opportunities you give them to yourself
and the opportunities you get can get
taken right away and we're thinking
we're thinking about moving and i gotta
be honest with you i'm for no other
reason
and me and ben literally just threw a
[ __ ] we looked at
america and we threw a [ __ ] pin
at the country and and and we didn't
even know where he was going to go we
were thinking about maybe austin texas
and it's just and we threw a pin and it
was the room was dark
and the map was dark and we just threw a
pin
and i said what is that and it was
austin texas and it's so
and again i don't know if we'll know
anyone there
i don't know if anyone we know lives
there probably not
will probably be alone will probably be
the biggest podcast in austin texas
if we move there i'm not saying
we will but i imagine if we do we'll be
number one
pretty quickly but maybe we'll go there
i don't know i spoke to a realtor i
called a realtor but you know me and do
a little fake business i don't know if
it becomes real business but i i i'm a
little sick of the idea
when you sit in la and you sit in these
restaurants
and you watch how silly this
town is how sad
it is uh in la you have two extremes of
people you have
16 year olds who've just arrived the
tick tock kids who are running around
the paparazzi are chasing them
they they've got to you know they've got
it's a quick burn their careers but
they're getting
money stuff down their throat uh they're
having a ball
um and then on the other side you have
people that won't let
fame go they won't let it go they just
you know they're holding onto it for
dear life
that both of those things are very
interesting to watch
you're between both of them in la you
have people that are
relevant for no reason immediately
uh who are like just in a daze during a
haze
these kids don't even know what's
happening they're just being followed
around
by paparazzi they're making all this
money some of them are savvier than
others but they're
they're just like wow what the [ __ ] and
then on the other end you have people
that are
just at the end you know
they're they've they've done it they've
done what they came to do
and many of them don't know that yet no
one's informed them no one's pulled them
aside and said
you've done this you did it it's time to
graduate
here's your diploma now walk out you
should have did this
years ago walk out with the class now
you can't keep coming back into the
school we know you like the pep rallies
we know you like the pep rallies we know
you like homecoming
we know you enjoy it we know it's fun
and you feel
just like you felt the first time you
did it but i'm here to tell you this
everybody's creeped they're creeped out
you know and i'm telling you it's like
grizzabella if you've seen
cats it's a gay podcast i [ __ ] on sports
i'm talking about cats but
isabella in in in the play cats
is like an old uh and and
she's like she sings memories
and she's like this ratty cat that walks
out and that's what you have
in hollywood you got a bunch of ratty
cats walking around they don't know it's
time to go
die and cats go die alone sometimes you
gotta go
die alone whitney was making me left
whitney cummings was like obsessed with
helping animals
and uh which is what i like about her if
she helped people it would be grotesque
but i liked it she loves animals and uh
she kept picking up a cat on her way
back to the comedy store taking it to
the animal hospital and they kept going
the cat's just trying to die like cats
go alone to die
so like literally this cat is trying to
die and the whitney's like putting it on
her instagram like
saved it again and the cat's like let me
die
so that's what la is there's a lot of
people there that you just got
let them walk out but i look and i go
what's my place here you know what's my
place what am i going to do am i really
am i going to walk around jake paul's
compound you know with an ar15 and
protect him am i going to
what am i going to do what what is my
purpose here what is my point
i i sit in a boa steakhouse and i i
stare at these these
uh kids and they're walking around you
know with face tattoos
and they roll on on drugs i've barely
even heard of
you know uh you know they're just
they're just
dancing you know they're dancing in
front of their cream spinach and they're
making more money
than i could even ever imagine you know
and i'm just sitting there like where do
i fit into all of this
what am i gonna be in the merch is that
what i'm gonna do is that why i came to
la to sell
t-shirts i just wanna sell merch
this is my new shirt new drop some new
drops coming
new merch shops coming we're dropping it
it's getting dropped it's merch things
you can wear
things you can wear you wear them i sell
them you buy them
i'm an artist is that what we're here to
do folks
you want sneakers now we are going to do
merge and don't
don't when i do that don't come back
with this and tell me i've done the
wrong thing i'm not letting it become my
whole identity that's the point
that doesn't mean i'm not going to do it
i've done it in the past but i mean
the excitement people have over merged
get it it's getting dropped is that
we're supposed to i mean the now kids
make a trillion dollars
every time they do a drop it says full
send
they've got make billions of dollars
those kids
i like those kids i i because they
embrace the darkness of the world in a
different way
they go to college campuses and tell
everybody to just
[ __ ] the corona out of each other and
jump headfirst into a pool
and do all the drugs and you know light
your parents car on fire i respect that
you know they do fun pranks like i don't
know they drink beer in front of cops
and
get in fights they go to jail they try
to recreate 911 all of that stuff
i think is good it's interesting it's
better than a lot of the [ __ ] my friends
are doing
let them do it good for them but the mur
i mean the merch these p
they just go wild with the merch
everybody what young kid they just want
that full send
and god love them send me a full sense
sweatshirt and i'll wear it
but is that what we're supposed to do
are we supposed to hang out in l.a and
just meet
and talk about merch until we both blow
our brains out
is that what i'm gonna do to design a
hoodie
my other merch is a joke it's fun you
should wear it it's cool but it's a joke
we got a guy to do a sketch it's a it's
a bit
and it's funny i'm gonna sit down now
and like i'm a designer like i'm a
fashion designer and you look at me you
go i want
merch from ham what is that
comedians are now that
can you imagine some guy talking to
kenneth and be like now you're you're
also a stylist
how did that come about yeah i've got a
new line of merch
about my time as a tent preacher sam
kinnison's doing a new
i don't know i just look around at la
and i go where do i fit
where do i fit 97 of people that do
comedy are mentally ill
three percent of us are mentally ill and
funny
it's the only difference
you got two clubs in la you got the
improv and the comedy store and the ice
house
okay and flappers
and i love the the ice house and i love
the improv and i love the store but i
don't know when things are open i don't
know when garcetti is going to open that
up
they were going to do shows in the park
a lot of the comedy store and they
[ __ ] they already
said no right somebody ratted them out
some rat um
you know the saddle ranch which is next
to the conversation
it's uh you want to talk about a
horrific restaurant
i mean hurt beyond like it's like
chicken fingers
it's the most popular restaurant in la
right now
they've set up tables and chairs in the
parking lot
and the tick tock kids go in there and
they throw chicken fingers at each other
what is why is the earthquake not here i
mean
what is going on how do you take this
place seriously
how does one grow old here with any
dignity
explain that to me show me how
i get it why rupaul went and started
fracking
okay i'm gonna start fracking if i make
a little more money on this patreon i'm
gonna go to
you know rupaul's got [ __ ] gas lines
in kazakhstan
and i get it what are you gonna [ __ ]
do sit at the saddle ranch
and eat coleslaw while 15 year olds
finger [ __ ] each other
in front of the paparazzi you got to
move into other things
christ almighty i used to like l.a when
i first met benjamin
we used to sit in benjamin's uh
garage and watch info wars and you know
the news
and we'd have a lot of fun and we did
sketches and they were fun and we'd go
and do
spots and we'd go to the house of pies
and eat pies which were good
but not great but ben really loved them
but
did i get you the brimey farms pie i
didn't get it for you
uh the one me you and ray did on in long
island
is that the one you're talking about
where we got the pie and the cider
no the primer is a raspberry cream from
from the the east
end by the hamptons we didn't get it
that time but that's the pie
but the point is you know at a certain
point you gotta just know when to hold
them know when to fold them i guess
what's coming good here show me what's
good
why am i stay why am i staying here
the business i'm in has melted it's
it is goo on the ground now
the idea of having a tv show is
embarrassing
it wouldn't bat you're embarrassed now
if you have a tv show
are you the guy from that show no
are you the guy from that show on true
tv where they talk about whose dog house
is better
no yes you are that's the guy from true
tv
are you the guy that hosts the hot dog
challenge no i'm not
please just drive me home i saw your
show it's really funny
it's an embarrassment already enough is
enough
we reno 911 arguably one of the funniest
shows of the last decade ends up coming
back on
quibby which is like this app
that's a [ __ ] complete mess where
you're supposed to download it and watch
high quality stuff
shows in seven minute increments it's
like a joke it's called quibby these
always have dumb names
nbc did something called cso now they're
doing peacock
and is everybody lining up to watch
peacock
what's your favorite show i like the
show on peacock
what are you saying sounds like a gay
bar
i want to go to peacock
i'm watching my shows on come stream
i mean i just think it's it's kind of a
joke now the show
is what we're doing the studio is is
what we make it and what we do the
videos are what we decide they are
the guests are who we book the live show
is what the live show is i mean
there's no other components here and
there's there's something a little
frustrating about that when you hit a
wall and you go oh wait a minute what's
the goal is to just try to keep being
funny and keep introducing new elements
to this show to make it better
and and and that is um that's
interesting and it's challenging but
i'll tell you this right now i i have a
very bleak
view of the future of of the mainstream
of this business and my place in it
specifically
and when you when you when you get rid
of that the reasons to live in la are
not that many
it's not a beach ain't that nice